Another type of depression is Seasonal Affective Disorder, or SAD for short.
For most individuals, episodes begin in the fall or winter, and then end when
spring arrives. This seems to be due to the reduced levels of life that we
experience during winter or colder seasons. For example, I spent most of my
life living in Michigan. And when winter rolls around, not only does it get
very cold, but it gets dark rather quickly as well. And that is not only due to
the shorter days that we experience during winter, but also to the cloudy
weather. We could go for days and days without seeing the sun. Now, I don't
think I actually had SAD, but I certainly did experience the winter blues. And
this is a nice example of how we may have some of the symptoms that are similar
to a disorder, but it doesn't necessarily mean we have the actual disorder
itself.